J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: So
we've talked
about the main events in NMR
spectroscopy for determining
structure.
That is, about the chemical
shift and about spin-spin
splitting, that allows you to
tell how many nearby
nuclei there are.
Today we're going to talk about
some complications that
make the spectrum more
complicated, and perhaps more
informative, in terms of high
order effects, higher-order
effects in spin-spin splitting.
And then about using NMR to
study, not structure, but to
study rates.
And we'll do some C-13
labeling stuff there.
So spin-spin splitting with
other nuclei besides protons
next door, and we actually saw
some of this last time with
deuterium splitting, with C-13.
splitting.
For example, if there's a signal
like this and you blow
it way up by 30 times, then you
can see that.
What gives these things that are
so far apart 126 Hz.
Do you remember this from last--
what are the size of splittings
you normally see
for protons that are on adjacent
carbons?
They're the order of 7 Hz,
right?
Here we have got 126.
What's the big thing that's
going on?
What makes coupling so big?
It's C-13-H. In fact, 99% of the
sample--
if you haven't specifically put
C-13s
in there, are C-12
but about 1% are C-12.
So you see that.
Now here's a paper from 1959,
which first noted something
interesting about these C13-H
coupling constants, that they
relate to the amount of
s-character in the carbon
atomic orbital that's involved
in the bonds.
Remember, we said that the
information has to be
communicated through the
electrons because the action
of magnets through space
if you average over all angles
of rotation in a liquid--
goes to zero.
So you communicate through the
bonds.
The nice thing about...
that it's so strong for JC13-H,
is that
C-13 has just one bond to get to
the H. So it's a very short
path to communicate.
Now, but you remember, also,
that to do that-- so that it
doesn't average out as you
tumble--
you have to have the electrons
in an s orbital.
So the hydrogen uses its s
orbital, that's all it's got
essentially.
But carbon can use s or p. So
the hybridization, as they say
here, relates to the coupling
constant.
Because to communicate that
electron must
be on the C-13 nucleus.
So this is a table from that
paper.
It gives the coupling constant
in units of per second.
Those were then changed to be
called Hz, nowadays.
So here are a bunch of different
compounds and
their JC13-H coupling constants.
If we make a histogram of them,
you see that there's a
group between 120 to 140
one between 150 and 170
and another group down around
250.
So there are different groups
involved here.
There are three different
populations, we could draw the
lines between them.
And then if we look to see what
the carbons are, that
bear these hydrogens that show
that splitting, we could look
first at the very big ones down
there.
And what's special about those
carbons that are
splitting the hydrogens?
They're triple bonded.
So sp hybridization
50% s in the bond to hydrogen.
The ones here, the green ones,
are in aromatic systems, so
they have sp squared
hybridization.
Except for cyclopropane.
Why would it have such a high
coupling constant?
Why would it have a lot of
s-character
in the bond to hydrogen
the carbon that's in the
cyclopropane?
Because its bonds normally are
tetrahedral-sp cubed
but when you try to make a
smaller angle, more
p-character in the bonds to the
other carbons, therefore
more s-character coming out to
the hydrogens.
So we can actually see that
hybridization change in the
NMR. And then these other are
normal methyl groups, I speak
sp cubed hybridized carbons.
So here in NMR, we have direct
evidence for this
hybridization stuff we talked
about last semester.
So it's sp, sp squared, sp
cubed.
Now here's a subtle point.
Perhaps we shouldn't be spending
time on it, but it's
so interesting. And I suspect
the curious among you may have
wondered about this.
Because we talked about coupling
goes through the bonds.
So from H to C to C to H. How
about H to C to H?
That's a shorter path.
So methane, if you're looking at
one hydrogen, how many
other hydrogens would you think
it would be coupled to?
Three.
And they could be in 1:3:3:1.
So you should see a quartet for
a proton of CH4.
But you don't, you just see a
single sharp peak.
So where did the splitting go?
And this is related to what we
talked about last time, where
a book said the splitting
constant is zero.
And I said that's not true, the
splitting constant is
high, maybe 10.
But it's not observable.
So why is it, why don't you see
quartets for CH4?
OK, so here's one of these
spectra-- actually if you go
up here and you can click on
that and get taken to the
website of Chem 220 where they
have problems. I'll work one
problem later in the class, if
we have time.
But there are others you can
practice on there.
So this is a compound, and I'll
tell you its answer.
It's cinnamic acid.
It's related to the adelhyde
related to this acid,
cinnamaldehyde is the smell of
cinnamon.
So what do we expect when we
look at the proton spectrum--
this is the proton spectrum of
it-- what do we expect?
Well, notice that we can draw
resonance structures, which
will put positive charge on the
carbon with that hydrogen,
so remove electron density from
that hydrogen.
Or from that one, or that one,
or that one.
So those all should be shifted
downfield relative to where
they would otherwise be,
relative to the ones that
aren't blue.
When we look at the compound,
then, we see these really
complicated peaks in here. We
throw up our hands trying
to understand that.
And then we see here two
doublets
really nice, sharp, clean
things.
So what do you think the two
doublets are out here?
Let's ignore that bit for the
time being and talk about
these two doublets.
Which protons do you think those
come from?
Which one is this?
OK, let me start going around
the compound.
The OH is way down further.
We're not showing that.
OK, so I go down.
I come to this one.
What do you think that is?
STUDENT: The one near the COOH.
PROFESSOR: No, that's the one up
here.
This is where double bonds
normally come.
Then you come here, and that one
has a hydrogen on double-
bonded carbon, but it's down
here because it's has lost
electron density.
Remember we drew a resonance
structure where the blue
ones were more positive.
And then here, we have hydrogens
that are on the
benzene ring, shifted down this
way because of the ring
shift, the aromatic ring current
that we
talked about last time.
And now there's a group of three
and a group of two.
These are positive and are
shifted down.
That's the group of two.
The group of three here is these
two, plus this one.
Which would be shifted down
because it's positive, but up
because it's far from this sp
squared carbon.
Let's not worry about why that
is.
But at any rate, that's the
benzene ones.
But that's not what we're going
to talk about here.
What we're going to talk about
is the clean
signals. Here and here.
Now this is measured with a
magnetic field of 7.05 Tesla.
That means it's a 300 MHz
spectrometer.
So instead of using parts per
million down here, we could
change to Hz if we wanted to,
change
to a frequency scale.
And in terms of frequency, if we
call zero the middle, then
that's lower-frequency to the
top, higher-
frequency to the bottom.
It turns out that the ratio of
the chemical shift difference,
delta--measured in Hz, not in
parts per million
we want to be comparing apples
with apples
here, Hz with Hz--
so the chemical shift from here
to here is much bigger
than the coupling constant, J.
It's 24.4 times as large, and
that's the pattern we see.
Now suppose we used a smaller
magnetic field.
What's going to happen?
The chemical shift in parts per
million
will stay the same.
But it'll be the same fraction
of a smaller frequency. If we
use a smaller field.
The precession frequency gets
smaller.
So if we measure in Hz, as we're
doing here, they'll come
closer together
but J will stay the same,
because it doesn't
depend on the field.
The magnets are not dependent on
the
field, they're coupling.
So what will happen?
These two doublets will move
together.
So at 2.89, it turns out the
ratio is 10.
Or at point.
0.86 Tesla, it would be 3.
Notice, incidentally, that this
would be a much cheaper
spectrometer because it would
have only 1/10 as big the
magnetic field as the other one.
But also, those other peaks are
going to be in the middle.
Everything's going to be getting
on top of one another,
and I'm just showing you what
would happen
to this double doublet.
There it is at 0.29.
And finally, if we're 100 times
smaller at 0.2 for the ratio
of chemical shift to J,
measured in the same units, in
Hz, you get the purple pattern.
Now notice that the J is always
the same, the splitting
between the two peaks
but what do you notice between
the doublet?
What's curious about this?
I mean, I'm sure you all see.
Some of the peaks are
disappearing and others are
getting stronger as they come
together.
The outer peaks are getting very
weak.
And in the limit where the
chemical shift was zero, the
difference-- as in methane--
then the outer peaks disappear
altogether and you
just see one peak.
Now notice that that part in the
original spectrum was a
mess, because all those
hydrogens of the benzene ring
have similar chemical shifts,
and they're all coupled with
one another so it's more of this
same thing
and all on top of one another,
and very complicated. So we'll
forget that.
Let's think about what causes
this change.
This is a so-called higher-
order effect
not the simple thing, that you
have a chemical shift, count
the neighbors and get 1:2:1,
1:3:3:1, 1:4:6:4:1
kind of thing.
So here we're plotting the
energy in a big applied field
of different nuclear spin
states.
And we're talking about just two
nuclei.
So they could both be with the
field; that
would be low in energy.
Or one with and the other
against, or one against and
the other with.
And then they could both be
against the applied field.
So you'd have these different
energies, right?
And that's the 100 MHz, that's
the energy that it
would take to get from here to
here by flipping the red spin,
would be 100 MHz.
But all these look the same,
whether you do a red line and
flip the red arrow, or do a blue
line and
flip the blue arrow.
They're all the 100 MHz or
whatever frequency, or 300
MHz in that spectrum we were
looking at before.
So we're going to see just a
single peak at first glance.
But if we home in and magnify
things so we can see small
differences, so enlarge this
center portion by a factor of
10 to the fifth so we can see
the difference is just a part
per million in the difference
between the environment of the
blue and the environment of the
red proton.
Then as we expand it, we see
that they're
not quite the same.
It's harder to flip the blue
proton than it is to flip the
red proton.
The blue proton is in a higher
field because of the chemical
shift difference.
And if we call that difference
delta/2, now you'll
notice that that made the red
lines shorter by delta/2
and the blue lines longer by
delta/2 doing that.
So now we're going to see a
chemical shift of delta.
One is smaller by delta/2, the
other larger my delta/2,
the difference is delta, the
chemical shift.
So that's the chemical shift.
And now suppose the spins
interact not only with the big
blue field, but also with each
other.
And just suppose that their
coupling through these
electrons is such that they
prefer to be anti-parallel.
You could have the opposite sign
of the coupling constant,
they could prefer to be
parallel.
But let's suppose they prefer to
be anti-parallel.
So the ones where they're
anti-parallel will go down in
energy, the ones where they're
parallel will go up in energy.
So let's do that.
And now what happened to the red
and blue peaks?
Notice that this red transition
went to lower
energy, but this one went to
higher energy.
And this blue one went to lower
energy, but this blue
one went to higher energy.
Everybody see that?
So what's going to happen?
The red peak is going to split.
There's going to be a lower and
a higher red peak, there's
going to be a lower and a higher
blue peak.
So it's going to look like that.
And that's going to be J. If
these shifts are J/4,
this transition got longer by
J/2, this one got shorter
by J/2.
So the difference between them
is J now.
In terms of the energy of the
things interacting with one
another, that's where we get
chemical shift difference, and
spin-spin coupling J.
OK, so that looks just fine, and
that's what's called the
first-order spectrum.
That's what we've been talking
about.
But there are higher-order
effects, and I think you'll
find this cute.
Because J does something else
besides just shifting these
levels, it also mixes this state
with this state.
And it mixes them into a sum and
a difference.
And of course we've seen things
just like this before.
That's what it looks like in the
case of magnetism.
The sum has the two pointing
opposite directions along z,
but not along x. And the
difference has them pointing
opposite directions altogether.
When you do that, when you mix
this with this.
You get the difference, which
turns out to be a little lower
in energy. And the sum, which
is a little higher in energy.
And of course, that's just like
mixing a p-orbital on
carbon with a p-orbital in
oxygen in a C=O double bond.
You mix the two, their energies
don't match, so this
one has more of that in it, this
one has
more of that in it.
Oops, I wrote this wrong, it
should be red and blue
I'll change that.
Everybody with me?
So I didn't tell you exactly why
it couples to
this, but it does.
So this shifts those energies.
Notice that that makes the reds
a little bit smaller,
both of the reds smaller.
And both of the blues larger.
So it shifted the reds to the
right and the
blues to the left.
So delta isn't exactly what you
thought it
was going to be.
That is, the difference between
the average of those
two isn't exactly the chemical
shift, because of this higher-
order effect.
But there's something much more
interesting that happens.
That one is non-magnetic,
obviously.
They cancel one another.
But how about the other one?
It's not magnetic along z, but
it's just as magnetic along x
as either of those other states
the top one or the bottom one
is.
So it has this resultant.
So it as magnetic perpendicular
to the main
field as either the one that was
where they're both against
the field, or the one where
they're both with the field.
So this one is magnetic, and
that one's not magnetic.
That is, this one can interact
with the magnetic field of
light, but this one can't
interact with the magnetic
field of light.
So if we look over here, we see
that this one is weakened.
It's not interacting with light.
This one is interacting even
more strongly with light.
Now what that means is this one
is really strong. And this
one is weak now, in terms of
interaction with light.
So this influences the intensity
of the transitions.
Now what it does, is it makes
the ones that involve this
level-- that's this red one and
this
blue one get stronger--
and these get weaker.
Like that.
So what's going to happen over
here?
This one, which is the shortest
of all, and this one
which is the longest of all,
this one and
this one get weak.
Pardon me, this is the longest
of all.
This is the shortest of all,
this red one.
So those get weak, but the inner
ones get strong.
So it changes to look like that.
And the more you mix them...
They're separated by delta or
delta/2, they're mixed by J. So
the bigger J is compared
to delta, the more they'll mix,
the more they'll be exactly like
this, which is when
they're completely mixed.
And the stronger these will
become and the weaker these
will become
So as the delta gets smaller and
smaller, in terms of Hz
as you change the magnetic
field, the outer peaks shrink
and the inner peaks grow.
So that's why methane has a
single peak and you can't see
it splitting.
Even though the coupling is
still there, you
just can't see it.
So the radio frequency light
loses its handle on the
flanking peaks as delta becomes
small compared to J,
as shown here.
So by increasing delta, measured
in Hz, that is by
using an expensive, big field,
you make things look more like
first-order spectra that are
easy to interpret.
1:2:1, 1:3:3:1, 1:4:6:1 and so
on.
So that's the subtle aspect.
Now we're going to talk about
how you use NMR to study
dynamics, to study rate
and what we mean by the NMR time
scale, and
how decoupling works.
So we looked at this spectrum
last time, this is a spectrum
of ethanol measured as it says
over here by your own
TA, Phillip Lichtor.
If we look at these three peaks,
we see there the OH,
the CH2, and the CH3, and we
analyzed these last time and
saw that this is a triplet, this
is a triplet, both being
split by this CH2
but this one is a quartet of
doublets.
Now that was measured in DMSO
solvent for a special reason.
Remember, that peak came from
DMSO that had a little
hydrogen in it, as well as
deuterium.
If we measured it in chloroform
with a little bit
of acid in there--
or if Phil did, he measured this
one as well--
notice the peaks shift a little
bit.
Especially the OH peak shifts a
lot, the others shift a
little bit, this one not too
much.
What's much more interesting
than these shifts is what the
peaks actually looked like, in
terms of their splitting.
Now bear in mind this OH peak is
here.
It's now over here, but I'm
drawing it here.
So instead of a triplet, it's
now a singlet.
And this one, instead of being a
quartet of
doublets, is just a quartet.
No changes over here.
We've lost the splitting between
the H and the CH2.
It's no longer split.
It's not split by the CH2, and
the CH2 is not split by the H.
So what's going on when we did
this?
In fact, what happens if we
don't have the acid in there?
If we don't have the acid in
there, this peak
moves way over here.
This one stays the same place,
we're still
in chloroform solvent.
And this one stays the same
place, but
the OH really changes.
But what's, again, much more
interesting is what the
patterns look like.
They look like that now.
So this, instead of being either
a triplet or a singlet,
is a really broad, low peak.
This one still looks a little
bit like a quartet of
doublets, but it's much
broadened.
This one is the same as it was
before.
So something really funny is
happening here.
Now let's look at the integrals.
So within experimental error,
it's 1 to 2 to 3.
It's 0.96 to 2, to 3.04 in DMSO.
In CDCl3, it's 1.00 to 2.00 to
3.05, again with an
experimental error 1, 2, 3.
But the one that had a little
bit of acid in it is much more
interesting.
It's 2 to 3, that's fine.
But this is bigger, 1.14.
So that peak-- this sharp peak
here, the one that has
acid in it, is bigger.
There are more protons there
than just one.
How did that happen?
It's an average of both the OH
that's on the
alcohol and the H+.
Now let's see, how did that
happen?
Well, H+ can go onto the
alcohol, and then the H that
was on the alcohol can come back
into the solution.
So we've exchanged those two
H's.
And if that happens rapidly,
there are H's moving all over.
Most of the time they're on
alcohol but some time--
14%--
there as H+ and what you're
seeing is the average
of those, in this case.
So this is averaging.
The H's are zipping around not
only between acid and alcohol,
but from one alcohol to another
alcohol,
by way of the acid.
And what that means is,
remember, the reason we see
splitting is that there are
these spin isomers.
There are different molecules in
there.
Some molecules have the
neighboring CH2 both up, some
have them both down, some have
one up and one down.
But if you're zipping from
molecule to molecule very
rapidly, you see the average.
Which is nothing.
So when we have acid in there
and it's averaging very fast
by going on and off and then
going to different molecules,
then we see a sharp peak here,
the splitting disappears.
Here, what's going on?
Well how about the ROH chemical
shift, that thing?
It's the average of many
hydrogen bonded structures,
because the hydrogen bonds keep
getting made and broken
very rapidly.
So you average among many
different hydrogen bonds, but
the H stays with the original
molecule.
It's not going from molecule to
molecule. It's just breaking
hydrogen bonds and going back
and forth.
And how fast you do that and how
much you do it depends on
concentration, on what the
solvent is, on the
temperature, and so on.
But how about the spin-spin
splitting between
the CH2 and the OH?
That can be the average
involving H-exchange among
many molecules.
It's fast if you have H+.
It's slow in DMSO.
So in DMSO, you saw H's staying
with their molecule,
and you see they're splitting.
In H+, they go from molecule to
molecule fast. You
see the average.
And what happens if you have
chloroform, but you don't have
the H+?
Some kind of averaging is
beginning to
happen, it looks like.
So it's clear that if you have
H+ in
there, it can zip around.
What happens if you're just
making and
breaking hydrogen bonds?
Well, you could have three
alcohols hydrogen bonded
together in a circle.
And they could trade which
hydrogen, so this is a
mechanism for exchanging
hydrogens from
one alcohol to another.
And then as the trimer comes
apart and the molecules become
another trimer and do this
exchange, another, another,
another, this is a mechanism-a
slow mechanism,
much slower than this H+ thing--
which can allow slow averaging
of the Hs.
But if you have DMSO as the
solvent, this doesn't happen.
Why?
Because DMSO forms very strong
hydrogen bonds with the OH,
and it doesn't form these
trimers in which the hydrogens
can shift from one molecule to
the other.
If DMSO were a strong enough
base, it could pull the H off
and be like an acid catalyst, it
would be a base catalyst.
Pull it off one molecule, put it
on another one.
But it's not that strong a base,
it's just strong enough
to forbid forming those hydrogen
bonded trimers.
So we can get this averaging.
But wait a second, we looked at
this one a couple lectures
ago when we were looking at IR.
And we said that even though
this was said to be an
anhydrate, it had these water
peaks.
And we said there were two kinds
of water peaks.
There are the ones that are
hydrogen bonded here, and the
ones that are not hydrogen
bonded.
That's two different peaks.
But shouldn't those average the
same way they do in NMR
where as you go from molecule to
molecule as the molecules come
apart and come together in
hydrogen bonding, you quickly
average those?
Why don't you get averaging in
the IR when you do get
averaging in the NMR?
Another question is, what's
fast?
How fast does it have to be to
see a blur, or to see the
average as a sharp average,
rather than to see the two
distinct things?
This particular sample is a
solid, so you could imagine
that these are held in place by
the surrounding molecules.
But you see the same effect in
solution, so that's not the
difference.
Now notice that in IR, we have
wave numbers here to tell us
how fast this is vibrating and
how fast this is vibrating.
And this one is 110 x 10 to the
10th Hz, and this OH
bond is 102 x 10 to the 10th Hz.
That is, the difference between
them is
10 to the 11th Hz
whereas the difference we were
looking at in the alcohol
things were 100 Hz or a few
hundred Hz, at most. So
this is a much bigger frequency
difference here in
IR than it was in NMR. What does
that
have to do with anything?
How long does it take to measure
a frequency precisely?
How long is long for purposes of
an average?
Well suppose you have two
different swings.
I'm going to put these two guys
on swings up to the
ceiling and they'll start
swinging.
And they swing at a certain
rate, but they won't swing at
exactly the same rate if they're
a little bit
different, the two swings.
This is pretty fast swinging.
One of them swings a 20 Hz, and
the other
swings at 21 Hz.
And I'm going to try to push
them, but I'm not going to
adjust the frequency I'm pushing
at.
I'm just going to sit here and
go bum bum bum bum
bum bum bum bum bum.
And I'm going to do it a 20 Hz,
So the guy that's swinging
naturally at 20 Hz, I
always push him every time he
comes, just right.
So the light field in the IR
case, or the NMR case, matches
perfectly for 20 Hz but it
doesn't match for
21 Hz, of course.
If I just did it for a little
while on the 21 Hz just for
a little while, it would be
almost in phase and I'd be
pushing them.
But after a little while, we'd
get out of phase,
and I'm pushing when
he's coming and then pulling
when he's going and so on. So
it's going to get out of whack.
How long does it take to get out
of whack?
How long do I have to be doing
this in order to find out that
I'm not really doing anything
with him?
Well notice that a one-second
pulse samples the full range
of phases, from being completely
in phase to coming
back to being completely in
phase again.
So if I do it for one second, I
get nothing.
It just cancels.
On this one, everything was
golden.
But obviously, then, there's no
net interaction with the
light in that one over the
course of one second.
So a one second light pulse can
clearly distinguish
between 20 Hz and 21 Hz.
Everybody with me?
That means... Suppose we have 22
Hz, a swing that I'm trying with
my light to hit
but I'm going at 20 Hz.
So that goes through two
complete cycles there.
In fact, if it goes through one
complete cycle
you can tell it's not working
after only half a second.
That is, 1 over the difference
in lambda.
That's long enough to sample the
full range favorable and
unfavorable.
So I can more quickly tell the
difference when the
frequencies are more different.
It depends on 1 over the
frequency difference, that's
how long I have to go to know
that I'm not going to get any
action out of it.
Now here's the interesting
thing.
Suppose the frequency is
changing in time.
It's averaging, a proton is
jumping from one position to
another and changing its
frequency.
Suppose that it goes at 22 Hz
for a while, then at 20
Hz for a while-- it's in a
different environment.
Then at 22 Hz, then at 20 Hz,
then at 22 hz, then
at 20 Hz for a while.
It's jumping back and forth
randomly at a certain rate.
Now obviously, that's not going
to work with the 22
Hz light.
It goes in and out of phase, so
we won't get any absorption
of 22 Hz light.
Suppose we try 20 Hz light, so
we'll move it up there.
Again, it goes in and out of
phase.
No profit in that one.
But suppose I try 21 Hz.
Now it stays pretty much in
phase, so
it's averaging properly.
And so what we will see is we
have a very good match at 21 Hz,
the average frequency, and we'll
see a single sharp peak.
21 Hz will work, 20 Hz won't,
22 will. [correction: won't]
We'll see an average peak.
What's determining?
It's how long the pulse is
compared to the
difference in frequency.
If the pulse is long enough, as
long as the difference in
frequency, then we can tell it.
So when do peaks average?
When atoms don't stay put long
enough to tell the difference
in frequency between the two
sites that
they're changing between.
So if two peaks differ by 100
Hz, you have to count for
a hundredth of a second,
roughly, to tell them apart.
But in the IR, they differed by
10 to the 11th Hz.
So the exchange of position
would have to be 10 to the
11th times a second in order to
be able to
see separate peaks.
That's as fast as atoms vibrate.
They can't change their partners
that rapidly.
So that's why in the IR you
don't see averaging when you
do see it in the NMR. Because
the NMR differences in
frequency are small, just a few
Hz or a
few hundreds of Hz.
So if something happens in a
hundredth of a second, you can
see separate peaks for it.
But you can't do that in the IR
because the differences in
frequency are so large.
So this gives rise to what's
called the NMR time scale.
Now suppose you had
cyclohexane-d11.
It gives this spectrum.
It gives a spectrum for axial
and equatorial hydrogens.
Incidentally, notice that that's
sort of as if this were
like benzene with the ring
current.
It gets shifted down when it's
out the side, and shifted up
when it's along the axis.
At least, that's a way to
remember it.
I'm not really sure that that's
the explanation.
I'm not really sure that ring
current is true.
But anyhow, you can remember
which is which if you want to.
Now notice this is a special
molecule, d11
just one proton.
And the reason is that you would
get very complicated spin-spin
splitting if these are all
hydrogen.
Because the axial will be split
by that, this equatorial
will be split by that axial one.
Because they don't have the same
chemical shift, so
they're going to split one
another.
And then they'll also be split
by these with different
coupling constants and so on.
So if we make all those
deuterium, we get sharper
peaks so we can study it.
So it's d11.
But notice this is at minus 89
degrees centigrade.
And watch what happens if you
start warming up.
The difference in chemical shift
is point 0.48 ppm,
and this was measured in an old
spectrometer in 1964
by Frank Bovey at Bell Labs.
And the difference here is 0.48
ppm
at 60 MHz,
or it's 29 Hz.
We have to put it in frequency.
If we want to talk about this
kind of thing.
So 29 Hz difference in
frequency.
Now we go from -89 dregrees to
-68 degrees.
The peaks get broad.
To -63 degrees, broader still
and moving in.
At 60 they coalesce and become a
single
peak at -60 degrees.
At -57 degrees, it starts
sharpening up, and sharpened
up still more at -49 degrees.
And what do you think it looks
like at room temperature?
A single, really sharp peak
as sharp as these or sharper.
So it's a single sharp peak up
there.
Even if you have C6H12 because
it's flipping back and forth
rapidly enough that it's
averaging the chemical shifts.
And once the chemical shifts
become the same on average,
then you can't see the splitting
anymore.
So cyclohexane gives a single
sharp peak.
But this allows you to tell how
fast, because you know
this frequency difference.
So it turns out that they
coalesce to give a single peak
when it's at about that same--
the lifetime is about the same
as that.
It's actually four times that,
but for qualitative purposes
it's the same at the time they
coalesce.
So it's about 100 times a second
that it's flipping back
and forth at -60 degrees.
But you can measure this, you
can fit these lines to
theoretical calculations for
rates at other temperatures.
Or you can go to a different
spectrometer which has the
same chemical shift difference,
but a bigger
frequency difference.
And then get at what temperature
you'd have that
frequency, or four times that
frequency.
So that's a great way to measure
the rates, and by
measuring the rates at different
temperatures, you
can get what the barrier is.
And that's where we got the
number from last semester. When
we were talking about
conformational analysis.
We said that the barrier for
flipping one chair to another
in cyclohexane is 10.5
kcal/mole, and
that's where you get it.
It's not easy to measure
something like that, but NMR
allows you to do it.
So this is a handy way to
measure really fast rates and
very small barriers that
correspond
to these fast rates.
So the NMR application in
dynamics is very important for
studying fast rate processes.
Let me see how much time.
Let me just go very quickly, I'm
going to go really quickly
through this so we can get to a
little bit
of something else.
But this was the kind of
question that I
might ask on an exam.
The first part, Question 1, had
to do
with making this molecule.
We've talked about making
hemiacetals before.
But the relevant part here is
Question 2, which was to
sketch what you'd expect for the
NMR
spectrum of that compound.
So let's look at the different
groups and you predict what
we're going to get in terms of
chemical shift.
First, (a). How about its
chemical shift, where do you
expect it on the spectrum?
The OH?
STUDENT: Downfield.
PROFESSOR: It'll be downfield
because of the O, but it'll be
almost any place because of the
hydrogen bonding and so
on, that has a big range.
And how about the splitting?
Should it be a singlet, a
doublet, a triplet?
quartet, quintet?
1:4:6:4:1?
What determines the splitting of
this?
How many protons are on the next
adjacent atom.
So we couple through this bond,
this bond, to here.
These are too far away.
Those are removed by one, two,
three, four bonds.
But to here, it's only one, two,
three bonds.
So it should be a doublet,
right?
Everybody agree it should be a
doublet?
Sebastian, you shake your head
slightly.
STUDENT: Well, it depends on
what the solvent is.
PROFESSOR: Ah, in DMSO, it would
be a doublet.
But mostly, you don't use that.
And in chloroform, it would be
exchanging so you wouldn't see
the splitting.
So it could be almost any place
between 1 and 6 for
hydrogen bonding, and the
splitting is...
probably it would
be a broad singlet
because of rapid OH exchange.
OK, now let's go to (b). Where
should that
be, chemical shift?
Way at the right, way at the
left, in the middle,
almost to the right?
STUDENT: Way at the right.
PROFESSOR: So it's hydrogens
that are on a carbon and the
next atom is carbon too.
That's up at the right.
But it has a couple oxygens
here.
So it'll be shifted down a
little bit.
Slightly deshielded by two
oxygen atoms on the
neighboring carbon.
So one might predict someplace
between 1 and 2, and
there's a compound that's very
like that, that is at 1.3.
OK, how about the splitting?
This one?
Now it has three bonds to get
from here to here.
So that should be a splitting,
there's no exchanging there.
So it should be a 1:1 doublet,
split by--
and the J should be about 7 Hz.
OK, now how about (c), what
should it look like?
What should its chemical shift
be, relative
to, say, these hydrogens?
STUDENT: A doublet of
quadruplets.
PROFESSOR: Derek what did you
say?
DERRICK: I said a doublet of
quadruplets.
PROFESSOR: Not the splitting,
where should the chemical
shift be first?
DERRICK: In the middle.
PROFESSOR: It's attached to a
carbon.
What's that carbon attached to.
Amy?
AMY: Oxygens.
PROFESSOR: They are oxygens.
So it'll be shifted down more
than this one was.
Because it's closer to the
oxygens.
So it's deshielded by two oxygen
atoms on the same carbon.
So it would be between 4.5-
there's an analog
that's at 4.7.
Now how about, Derek, now you
tell us about the
splitting of this one.
STUDENT: I think it's a doublet
of quadruplets-- or a
quadruplet of doublets.
I don't know how to--
PROFESSOR: It would be -- if it
were split by this, that makes
it a quartet.
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And this would make
it a doublet, except we already
said that that's probably
exchanging.
It would depend on the solvent.
So probably it would just be a
1:3:3:1 quartet.
J about 7 Hz.
OK, let's keep going.
How about this one?
What's that going to be like?
Jack?
Chemical shift for that CH3?
STUDENT: 2.
PROFESSOR: Maybe about 2,
because it's attached to a
carbon which bears oxygen.
So slightly deshielded by the
oxygen.
That's rather like this one,
which is attached to a carbon
which bore two oxygens.
So not as far down as that.
1.1.
And how about the splitting of
that one, Jack?
STUDENT: It would be a doublet.
PROFESSOR: Just a doublet,
because
these are too far away.
1:1 doublet, 7 Hz.
OK, now let's go to (e). What's
it going to look like?
How about its chemical shift?
Debby?
STUDENT: It would be like 4?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because it's
got an
oxygen on the same carbon.
So it's 3.8.
Not bad.
And how about its multiplicity?
How many hydrogens splitting it
three bonds away?
I can't hear very well.
STUDENT: It would be...
I don't know.
PROFESSOR: Well, we already said
that this one is going to
be a doublet split by that.
If that's true--
if this one splits these, then
these split that.
STUDENT: So do the top ones.
PROFESSOR: So do the top ones.
So how many altogether?
STUDENT: So it's six hydrogens,
so its--
PROFESSOR: So it'll be seven
lines in
the binomial intensity.
Seven line multiplet from the
six atoms on
the neighboring carbons.
7 Hz.
So that's going to be really, a
whole bunch of them.
Seven lines.
OK, now how about (f)?
STUDENT: Like (d)?
PROFESSOR: Chris?
STUDENT: Same as (d).
PROFESSOR: Ah, same as (d). It's
got the same connectivity as
(d), same hydrogen coupling and
so on.
But it's slightly deshielded by
the oxygen atom there-- so
I copied that from here.
And I copied this from here, and
that's what you said.
But it's different from (d)
because
here is a chiral center.
So one of those is pro-R and the
other is pro-S. They're
different within another chiral
center.
So in fact, when you look at a
situation like that, there are
two that are really close to one
another.
Two doublets.
They're about the same, but I
caught you.
STUDENT: Can you see that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you do see
that.
Not in every molecule.
Notice it's an isopropyl group,
two CH3s on a CH
attached to something.
If the rest of the molecule is
chiral,
those will be different.
CHRIS: By how much?
PROFESSOR: That depends on what
the molecule is.
It's sometimes hardly
observable.
But very often, you can see it.
I saw one, when I was a graduate
student I got a
spectrum like that.
I said, what the heck is going
on?
So that was a standard question
I would ask on exams
down here of graduate students
at that time, after
I learned it myself.
OK now, proton decoupling.
Let me just start this, and then
we'll show the
example next time.
So we have JC13-H here.
Now notice that when we put this
in a certain magnetic field,
the proton will precess at 100
MHz.
How about the C-13?
Will it precess at 100 MHz?
No, because it's a much weaker
magnet.
It doesn't feel as much torque,
it doesn't precess as
fast.
So the H has a steady field in
that direction.
Or there are other ones that
have exactly the same steady
field in the opposite direction.
Now C-13 is 25 MHz, it's only a
quarter
as strong as a magnet.
So it precesses much more
slowly, it's a smaller magnet,
and it can be either up or down.
So both these things are
happening when we put it in a
magnetic field.
And here's the NMR spectrum, and
we've seen that, and saw
the satellites--
this peak comes from C-12s.
This is from C-13s when they're
down, and this is the proton
precession when the C-13 is up,
reinforcing the applied field.
And at the same time, if we
looked at the C-13 spectrum,
notice that essentially all of
hydrogen is protium.
Only 0.015%, very little, is
deuterium.
So you don't see that big peak
in the middle here, because
all the hydrogen is either this
way or this way.
And the magnitude of the
splitting in both
cases is 125 Hz, that's fine.
So now, suppose we do something
really cute.
Suppose we put two radio
frequencies in.
One at 100 MHz, one at 25 MHz.
But what we're going to do--
the way we're going to do it is
to irradiate 100
MHz all the time.
But just do a pulse, a 90 degree
pulse. Of the C-13 to twist it
down into the plane, and then
allow it to precess.
And that's what we're going to
listen to
see if we got a signal.
We're going to listen to the
C-13 while irradiating the H.
Now what effect does that have,
then?
If you were in a frame rotating
at 100 MHz,
you'd see that this little 100
MHz field is going to
cause the hydrogens to precess
like this.
To go up, down, up, down, up,
down.
What determines how fast they go
up and down?
How fast they precess?
What determines that?
It's how big this field is.
How strong the field is.
The stronger the field, the
faster the precession.
So that means H is going to be
up, then down,
then up, then down.
And how fast it's going up,
down, up, down, up, down
depends on how much power we put
into our radio.
If we do it fast enough, we see
the average of the C-13 and
decouple the spectrum.
We can see the C-13 spectrum
without the H splitting it, by
making the H's quickly go up and
down.
How fast do they have to go up
and down in order to average
the 125 Hz splitting to be
nothing, to
just be a single peak?
How fast?
Once you've had time to review
the lecture, you'll be able to
answer that.
STUDENT: 125.
PROFESSOR: About 125 times a
second, right?
The frequency difference is how
fast you
have to flip to average.
So if you put enough power in on
the hydrogen, you remove
the splitting from the C-13
spectrum, which can be handy,
as we'll show you next time.
So the decoupling power
determines the rate of this
precession.
And this, we'll see next time.